well maybe that tupperware bowl when it  gets out of here will feel more like the  holidays but the season certainly feels  like it's here the glittering lights are  back at las vegas motor speedway the  annual display features more than 600  animated and sparkling displays more  than 5 million led lights and if you're  going to go up there part of your entry  fee goes to local charities  we're so thrilled to be back and up and  running because it just brings everybody  a little bit closer together and  brings a little bit more love into  everybody's life  oh  and the glittering lights run through  january 9th tickets available now  glitteringlightslasvegas.com